so i have two triangles depicted here
and we have some information about each
of those triangles we know that this
side of this left triangle has length
eight we know that this side has length
seven and then we know that this angle
is 50 degrees
and on this triangle we see some things
that look a bit a little bit familiar
this triangle this side has length eight
this side has length seven and this
angle right over here has a measure of
50 degrees
so my question to you is can you
definitively say
not assuming that these are drawn to
scale because they actually aren't can
you definitively say that these
triangles are congruent or could you
definitively say that they aren't
congruent or can you not say either
would you have to say that there's not
enough information pause this video and
think about that
so essentially what we have here are two
pairs of sides that have the same length
and an angle but that angle is not
between those two sides if the angle
were here and here then we could use
side angle side side angle side to
deduce that hey these are congruent but
that's not what we're dealing with we
are dealing with side side angle side
side angle i'm saying the side and the
side before the angle because other if i
don't do that it becomes a little bit
crass so we're really saying a side side
angle sufficient to prove congruency and
the reason why it's not is that you can
actually construct different triangles
with the same constraints for example on
this rightmost triangle it could look
like this or it could look like this the
seven side
could go down like this
and intersect like just like that now
you might be saying hey that's not what
it looks like it looks very similar but
remember we're not going on looks we
have to go based on the information
they've given us and so you could just
as easily based on the information the
constraints they've given us have a
triangle like this and so the very fact
that you can create two different
triangles that are clearly not congruent
based on the exact same information the
exact same constraints tells you that
that information those constraints are
not enough to tell you that these are
congruent triangles